Американка Дженніфер Галлер стала першою у світі випробувачкою,
якій зробили ін'єкцію ймовірної вакцини від SARS-CoV2
43-річна мати двох дітей, широко посміхаючись,
розповіла репортерам, що їй було зовсім не боляче:
Я була першою, це неймовірно.
Я справді в захваті від цього. Це було легко.
Як щеплення від грипу.
Кілька місяців тому я вакцинувалася від грипу.
І  це дуже схоже. Не боляче, я всім задоволена.
Випробування вакцини стартували
16 березня у американському Сіетлі.
Їх проводить компанія Moderna.
Усупереч світовій практиці,
американці почали тестувати вакцину на людях ще до того,
як її дію випробували на тваринах.
це, на думку європейських науковців,
несе неабиякий ризик.
Утім, першопрохідців це не лякає.
Ммій стан здоров'я дозволяє
мені не надто турбуватися про це.
Але я знаю, що це справді важливо для мене
і для кожного з нас
Тож я намагаюсь зробити свій внесок та залишатись вдома
та не відвідувати громадські місця, де є скупчення людей.
Це перше щеплення Дженніфер Галлер
та іншим 44 відчайдухам -
тест на сприйняття організмом вакцини.
Якщо він пройде успішно, тоді через місяць вони отримають другу дозу,
вже власне для перевірки захисту від коронавірусу.
Тим не менше, навіть за найкращого перебігу випробувань,
аби створити вакцину для масового вжитку,
знадобиться від 12 до 18 місяців.
Епідемія, що загрожує світу, потребує глобальної відповіді.
Новий коронавірус уперше з'явився у місті Ухань,
але боротьба з цим захворюванням
точиться у багатьох країнах.
На початку січня група китайських науковців
оприлюднила генетичний код віруса,
що дозволило дослідникам у цілому світі
розпочати роботу над пошуком вакцини.
В університеті Гонконгу патологи намагаються
виростити новий коронавірус в людських клітинах,
аби довідатися більше про його властивості.
Перше, що люди хочуть дізнатися:
де саме у дихальних шляхах
або в організмі людини розмножується вірус.
Друге - якої шкоди він завдає організму
і як тіло на це реагує.
Кінцева мета у боротьбі з будь-яким вірусом - знайти вакцину.
Одна з команд працює в Бельгії
в університеті міста Льовен.
Зазвичай розробка й випуск вакцини
тривають 10-15 років.
Тому нині вся наукова спільнота намагається якомога швидше
знайти рішення й допомогти
у цій надзвичайній ситуації.
Дослідження бельгійської команди частково проводяться у роботизованій лабораторії,
яка відмежовує науковців від небезпечних патогенів.
Вони сподіваються, що за кілька тижнів їм вдасться
протестувати першу вакцину на мишах.
Але ще належить пройти довгий шлях між тестуванням на мишах
та використанням вакцини людиною.
Тому що треба провести усі можливі тести,
необхідний контроль якості.
Потім вакцину ще тестують на добровольцях.
Попри всі зусилля науковців
вакцина проти Covid-19, як очікуєтсья,
буде готова не раніше літа наступного року.
Тому дослідники також працюють над тим,
аби сповільнити поширення вірусу.
У столиці Німеччини Берліні фізик Дірк Брокман
та його колеги працюють над моделлю оцінки глобальних ризиків.
Аналізуючи різні дані, вони вираховують
ризик поширення захворювання для різних країн.
Ми надаємо консультації. Причому не лише у Німеччині.
Ця робота з моделювання ситуацій є дуже важливою.
У цій сфері моделювань інфекційних захворювань
усі команди в різних країнах світу дуже тісно пов'язані.
Ми обмінюємося між собою інформацією.
Такого не було у часи кризи Еболи або H1N1.
Це щось нове.
Вакцину проти коронавірусу розробляє
і німецька біотехнологічна компанія Curevac
Нещодавно розгорівся скандал довкола того,
що буцімто у розпал пандемії
президент США Дональд Трамп
начебто запропонував німецьким власникам
1 мільярд доларів
за ексклюзивні права
на вакцину й технологію її розробки -
виключно для США.
Однак після енергійного втручання уряду Німеччини
контракт, судячи з усього, було зірвано.
Ми відчуваємо велику політичну підтримку.
До проблеми дуже серйозно ставляться
з різних сторін.
Зокрема надала підтримку міжнародна ініціатива
з питань вакцинації.
Тож, клінічні випробування
можуть розпочатися доволі швидко.
Керівник досліджень Curevac Флоріан фон дер Мюльбе
розповів, що вже триває відбір осіб для перших випробувань вакцини.
І не виключено, що вже у червні-липні цього року
препарат буде готовий.
Після цього його почнуть випробовувати на людях.
Ми вже маємо досвід створення інших профілактичних вакцин,
наприклад, проти сказу.
Отримані результати дуже добрі.
І на цьому підґрунті ми створюємо нову вакцину.
Боротьба з новим коронавірусом - це змагання проти часу.
І хоча міжнародна реакція на вірус
була однією з найшвидших у новітній історії,
серйозне погіршення ситуації в Ірані,
Південній Кореї та Італії показало,
наскільки складним є це змагання.